heading for the cliff that's the focus
of tonight's angle
now as the angle noted last night
democrats are in a hypersonic panic over
the midterms in 2024.
they know they're headed for a crash
which is why they convened their
so-called summit for democracy yesterday
they're engaged in what i think is an
elaborate but quite transparent attempt
at preemptive spin
we've doubled the number of attorneys
defending and enforcing voting rights
laws to prevent voting discrimination
provide baselines for assessing the
accessing the ballot box the anti-voter
laws that many states have passed are
part of an intentional effort to exclude
americans from participating in our
democracy our congress must act
congress must act they know these putrid
bills are going nowhere and thus all
that's left is this
the jesse smollette defense to losing in
other words we're not losers we're
victims
victims of a racist system that
perpetuates white privilege that somehow
elected barack obama twice
and this is the party of hope and change
or at least it was that's really funny
so what's clear is that democrats are
headed full speed ahead to the cliff's
edge
not only are they not hitting the brakes
though they've cut the brake lines
altogether
the old party of fdr and jfk
is now more like the party of thelma and
louise
now you think i'm exaggerating here
the gop is leading the democrats now
by double digits in the generic ballot
for the first time ever in the cnbc
all-american survey
that's a 10-point lead
and biden's approval rating remains at a
pathetic 41 percent oh and it gets worse
the so-called urban ring counties those
surrounding cities
now prefer a republican control of
congress
by five points
okay do you remember i did all those
articles about how the gop has lost the
suburbs forever
now as hard as it is to believe it turns
out that a lot of suburbanites like safe
streets they like a strong economy and
strong border you bet according to the
same poll the most important issues for
voters are
inflation
immigration
and of course safety crime democrats
have bombed on h1
on the economy biden's approval by the
way is underwater now by a whopping 19
points and it's probably going to drop
even further on today's inflation
announcement it must up 6.8 up 6.8 and
this of course is a new record that is
the highest level since june of
1982 x food and energy year over year
it's up 4.9 that is the highest level
since june of 1991 we'll call it 30
years
any way you slice it inflation is raging
devastating workers wages and family
savings but after the white house
invited reporters over recently for a
special off-camera briefing
magically the press found reasons for
great optimism
to me we have the strongest economy
perhaps i have ever seen so people are
confident about their jobs i say
fantastic and the ability to even get
better ones if they want to they're
spending more than i've ever seen but
they're doing it with cash not on credit
they're doing so
in a rowing 20 style cost of the pump
finally easing up with the national
average for a gallon of regular falling
to three dollars and 35 cents the lowest
since october just look at that
how insulting and monstrously out of
touch
but at least joe biden has a smart
number two behind them who can step in
to offer sage advice in difficult times
oh wait with kamala harris the democrats
are between a rock and a hard place
if something should happen to biden
or if he doesn't run for reelection
which he won't
they're stuck now with an unqualified
unintelligent
and completely unlikable woman as their
presumptive frontrunner
in a hypothetical trump kamala harris
matchup trump receives 50 support harris
41 support trump would win the electoral
college in a landslide with that margin
and with their supposed backup plan
mayor pete
democrats are in even deeper trouble
in a trump buddha judge match-up the
former president receives an 11
point margin of victory
okay
this is what happens when you put
diversity over merit
talent and experience in the end always
went out
and it turns out that minorities value
competence and results
just as much as anyone else
so it makes sense that with the biden
wreckage piling up the gop is seeing a
huge gain among hispanic voters
a recent wall street journal poll notes
that hispanic voters are now evenly
split in their choice for congress 37
percent said that support the republican
congressional candidate and 37 percent
said that favor the democrat
now in 2020 biden beat trump among
hispanics by 30 points
but now in a head-to-head match-up the
journal recorded the vote is evenly
split
43-4
that is stunning and we're not just
talking huge gains in texas and florida
they're big gains for republicans in
parts of the northeast as well
so the lesson for republicans is obvious
trump's policies worked there's no going
back to the old perpetual war open
borders global globalist views of
yesteryear
soon they should if they're smart unveil
a new 21st century contract with america
cut middle cost taxes revive the oil and
gas industry through exploration
shake up education advance small
businesses reinvigorate american
manufacturing it's all a winning
strategy and any republican who goes
down the path of liz cheney
will just be joining the democrats in
their thelma and louise ending
[Music]
and that's
the angle hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else